alarming new video showing how far
smugglers will go
to get migrants across the united states
southern border a border patrol
surveillance camera recorded smugglers
climbing
a 14-foot barrier in new mexico and
literally dropping
two small children over the barrier to
the ground while child smuggling
isn't uncommon what you are seeing here
is at least for now agents rescued the
children one is a five-year-old
the other is three years old customs and
border patrol
say a lack of space covet 19 protocols
and legal requirements mean
some asylum seekers are now being
transported to rural communities
after they're stopped near the border
lilia luciano visited one of those small
towns in arizona
to see how people there are responding
after being picked up by border patrol a
few miles away
families like this one are now on the
next stop in their journey to asylum
we're in ajo this is a tiny town in the
middle of the desert
these border patrol vans just arrived
they're dropping off
a group of asylum seekers mostly family
units
nearly 300 people have arrived in this
small town of about 4 000
in the last week and a half this is the
first time it's happened in this
community aaron cooper runs the
international sonoran desert alliance a
community group that
functions like a local government this
is the middle of the desert why here
there's a substation 10 miles south of
here and so anyone who's apprehended in
that area of responsibility
they are being instructed to take them
to the nearest population center which
in this case
is being interpreted as zaho asylum
seekers are given a notice to appear in
immigration court
and in the past border patrol would take
them to tucson
now they say they don't have the legal
authority to do so
the small town with little resources
mobilized to handle the influx of asylum
seekers coming their way
were you guys even ready for this this
is not the first time
we've had to come together as a
community to solve a unique problem that
hit suddenly
ever since i was born you know first
thing you thought
take water in the desert help other
people 82 year old jose castillo says
the ajo volunteers who usually leave
water for migrants in the deadly desert
are now shifting gears to help these
asylum seekers along their journey
volunteers provide food and water and
test asylum seekers for covid
separating out positive cases the county
then uses these vans to transport them
to tucson
where there's housing and other
available resources
jose andres from venezuela arrived at
this shelter in tucson
i look in future a better future
back in ajo cooper says he's already
seeing volunteer fatigue
so when we went from one drop a day to
oftentimes two drops a day
very quickly we had volunteer burnout
and it turned from a
i'm willing to come and pitch in for a
few hours to this is a full-time job
something that really stood out to me is
most of the people
arriving here i talked to a mom from
venezuela who says they have no idea
where they are in fact the volunteers
set up a map on the wall to point
where ajo is and where they will go next
and how to get there
but it's important to point out although
a hundreds of people have arrived here
and other small town desert
towns in the desert the vast majority of
people who are apprehended at the border
according to border patrol
almost 90 percent of people are returned
immediately
gail i hear that but that speaks to the
desperation don't even know where you
are i just want to be there
it's better where you're coming from
thank you very much lilia